[Music]
[Music]
what's he doing in the back here what's
he doing in the back I see this picture
there's a there's a black house of cute
this is
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Vanessa
[Music]
[Music]
the bacon as I gotta gonna bake in under
for now matter like oh yes I got gonna
make bacon
bake the bacon Asahi couldn't be part of
the five pillars could be like many
Muslims make this journey once in a
lifetime if you're physically and
financially able it's the first house of
worship get this built by Abraham to
commemorate the worship of the One God
remember Salam is based on five pillars
when anyone can be a Muslim habib Todd
Berger came here from the US of Jewish
ancestry raised a Christian he converted
to Islam two years ago all pilgrims here
were the simple white Iran and all
markers of social status disappear as if
my family has concerns and issues and
they also recognize that I have a deep
connection with gods with the one god I
believe that people have no idea what
this love is originally from Texas Habib
now lives in California
he says his biggest challenge is to
change misconceptions in America about
Islam it's it's unfortunate that the
media in the States has portrayed as
long as it is because there's no
connection between
terrorism in Islam as Arafat day draws
to an end
many like Habib continue their prayers
in the spot where Muslims say Prophet
Muhammad delivered his last sermon the
other four pillars if you didn't know
are to testify what's in your very
nature is natural to believe in the
Creator they done scientific studies of
the god spot and all of us in Oxford
University not too long ago they did a
study and they concluded that the belief
in a creator is intrinsic it's an eight
it's built in all of us this belief is
something acquired so you do something
that is natural that's within your
capability that you give birth to what's
already inside you that there's nothing
worthy of worship nothing in the
creation except the one who created the
creation the one God the Creator and
Muhammad is the last and final messenger
this will automatically include not
exclude every messenger that came before
him with the same message submit your
will to God Almighty Allah that is the
first pillar second is to establish the
prayer five times a day minimum not
because God means it because we need it
we need a recharge of the heart to keep
it humble otherwise we get we get taken
away by this temporal world and we don't
remember we forget that this life is a
test and we got to prepare ourselves for
the day of judgment and we're gonna be
judged and evaluated just like in high
school college there's an evaluation
this life is that and those five pillars
help us to remain cognizant of our
purpose in life and the third is giving
in charity to the poor zakat fasting
during the month of Ramadan and this is
something Jesus did all the messengers
of God did they were all Muslims once
who submit to the will of God Habib is a
Muslim one who some instead of God you
could be a Muslim anyone could be a
Muslim anytime this is what a Muslim is
and it was our humble attempt to
familiarize you with some of the things
that this MMA fighter does so next time
you see him you watch him you can
appreciate them it's
something something that is foreign to
you now strange we've connected it to
things that you can relate to and if you
want to know more call us 1-866-376-8255
have my people reach out to your people
and insha'Allah God willing we can make
the connections and we can get to meet
and have you on the program thank you
very much everybody tuning in we'll see
you next time same time same channel
here on the Deen show like this video
subscribe if you haven't already peace
be with you something